i think that when i started out in
business i heard all these things in the
personal development space like uh you
should have you should read these
affirmations every morning i never did
that and it was because it felt stupid
to me now that being said there might be
some people who've had life-changing
results from doing that but what i did
notice is that the stories i would tell
myself about myself were the things that
changed my beliefs they were the things
that changed my character and so a lot
of times in some of my other videos i've
talked about how entrepreneurship is
about three things it's about changing
the beliefs that you have it's about
increasing the skill set that you have
and then the character traits that go
along with that to make sure the skills
are successful so i'll give you a simple
example for this so a friend of mine he
started a fitness app he was doing about
20 000 a month he was a crossfit games
competitor but he was really ashamed
because he wasn't the winner he was like
you know really really highly ranked one
but he wasn't the winner and so he
believed that his app wasn't good enough
and so he never promoted it so it grew
to 20 000 a month in revenue with him
doing zero promotion and when he
realized that it was okay for him to
promote it and people got a lot of value
from it in the app was good enough he
went from 20 000 a month to like 150 a
month like that and the difference was
his beliefs his skills were the same his
character traits are the same he changed
his beliefs so let me give you a
different example when i actually
started out getting in my own business i
had a chain of gyms you know this was 10
years ago i had janet gems i knew how to
run sales teams i knew how to generate
leads i need to do all these things but
what ended up happening was i had one
missing piece which was also a belief
darn i was actually trying to give you a
different one but i had a mentor come in
and say you need to get in the licensing
business you need to license this model
to lots of people rather than doing the
actual model yourself and so i did make
that transition and then we went from
two or three million dollars to doing
seven and the next year we did 28
million so the year that we made the
transition halfway through is what
jumped us from two or three to seven and
it was just in the last like four months
that we saw this crazy growth and then
we did 28 million the next year and so
it was because i had all these skills
and i also had the character traits i
just needed again to change about the
beliefs i was trying to give you an
example with the character traits let me
think of one so if you have uh for
example if i had had those skills but i
didn't have the character traits of
being disciplined and being focused on
one thing i would have jumped uh between
multiple you know entrepreneurial
endeavors and never been able to see
success because even though i had the
beliefs about what was possible um like
if i'd said okay i'm gonna do gyms and
i'm gonna do chiropractors and i'm gonna
do dentists i'm gonna do x y and z right
until i had the character trait of focus
the character trait of discipline um
then i would not have seen the success
right and so the next natural question
is okay well if i have to have aligned
beliefs skills and character traits at
each level of the ladder because you can
have and this is what's crazy when you
see the overnight successes this is what
happens i want to describe it to you so
you understand and how you can do it so
let's say that there's a ladder all
right and you've got this pole on one
side you've got the pole on the other
side you've got the middle bar okay
you need all three to move to the next
level of the ladder right and so for
example you might have the left side
built up six stories above where you're
at and you might have uh the right side
build up six stories you know uh are you
know ten stories from where you're at
right now but all of a sudden if you
change your character and that character
trait development gives you three more
rungs all of a sudden you go three rungs
because you already have the constraint
has been removed and so you can be more
advanced in your beliefs than you on
your skills or it can be more advanced
in your character trait than you are in
your skills or you can be more advanced
in your skills than you are on your
beliefs right and so it's having all
three of those that are checked off at
each level of entrepreneurship that gets
you to one one million dollars a year
three million or ten million dollars or
a hundred million dollars a year
whatever it is right is you have to have
all of them and so what i the point of
this video and i'm gonna is is to get
you to understand how to actually
develop those soft things because the
skills are straightforward right the
skills are you just go by the course and
you read the book and you consume the
content like this and you practice you
apply right that's what you have to do
that's it that's it right um one of the
skills that i see lots of marketers
these days not have is they don't know
how to sell they don't know how to
develop a sales team they don't know how
to manage and grow a sales team they
don't want to lead a sales team that's a
skill they don't have and as soon as
they do they go from 3 million to 10
million like that very very easily right
it's understanding that that's the skill
deficit and as soon as they do it boom
they blow up i was fortunate because i
had a ton of the skills in my skill
toolbox but i went from making nothing
to tons because i had all of these rungs
of this ladder already built out to a 30
million level except i just didn't have
the beliefs that was my issue candidly i
suffer from a lot of insecurities and so
my wife was the one who was like you can
do this like you don't have to have
these gyms like you can license out the
model like you can you can really
succeed like this and i honestly just
thought she was a really smart person
and very wise and so i trusted her
belief in me
before i really trusted it for myself
and so hopefully you can have something
like that in your life but maybe that
that could be me i trust in your i trust
in your your skills and your beliefs so
so hopefully you can borrow some of that
trust because i promise you the world
does get better when you when you take
those leaps of faith need motivation
watch a top 10 believe nation hey it's
evan carmichael and i make these videos
because you are probably the most
ambitious person in your circle but you
know you're capable of more and you get
that push by surrounding yourself with
the best so today let's learn from one
of the best alex hermosie and my take on
his top 10 rules of success
enjoy rule number two model wise men i
wanted to give you the simplest
single hack that i have used
inadvertently and seen a tremendous
amount of success that is
asking myself the question what would a
person who does this type of thing do in
this instance the one that i'll tell you
that i've repeated a lot to myself over
the years probably over the last five or
ten years
has been the repeated chorus of
what would a wise man do i think it's
because i did not consider myself to be
very wise and i acted many ways
that were unwise
earlier on in my life and i still
continue to do so but i tried to do less
of it right and i think that and i'll
borrow this again from james clear's
book your identity is much more of a
weighing system actually this is not
from this book but like it's much more
of a voting system where you you cast
votes in either direction based on your
activities of what type of person you
want to become and i think the simplest
distillation of that concept is simply
asking the question what would this type
of person do if you can use that as the
refrain that you come back to over and
over again the chorus of your day that
gets repeated over and over again i
think it's much easier than trying to
remember the 50-point checklist of all
the activities that you need to do to
achieve the goal in the the friend that
came back in my life um where we were
having this conversation i just
distilled it down to like what would a
billionaire do
and so when we're confronted with these
crossroads right you wake up in the
morning and you're like i don't know
what i should start it's like what would
a billionaire do and so basically what
you can do is have
a certain refrain or chorus that you ask
yourself what would this type of person
do and that type of person when you ask
that question is who you will eventually
become as you continue to cast votes
that reinforce the stories that we tell
ourselves about who we are and those are
the things that create long-lasting deep
change and what's more about this is
that these
changes when they become internal when
they become ingrained in our behavior
they become effortless but it takes time
and so i think that the mental cue that
i have given myself inadvertently over
the years i don't have a lot of courses
that i refrain to or that i come back to
over and over again and so i tweeted
about one and it got shared a zillion
times but is what would someone 10 times
smarter than me do in this situation
right and a different way of saying that
is what would a billionaire do and and
word in whatever way that resonates with
you but i think rather than having that
big checklist you can put just a little
post-it on your computer or wherever you
work that's a reminder to yourself
that this is the type of person i want
to become
and in order to become this type of
person i need to do these things because
those actions will reinforce the
thoughts that i say about myself because
the whole concept behind affirmations
that i do not like right which is i am a
you know i'm a lion i'm a tiger i'm a
whatever right just saying them doesn't
make them true unless you're a crazy
person and most of us are not crazy i
think right there's plenty of crazy you
don't get me wrong but if you're
probably watching this channel you're
probably at least semi-same right if we
have you know
this degree of sanity that's on our side
then what we have to do is create
something else which is evidence we have
to give ourselves evidence that we are
this type of person in order to become
that but how do you have evidence that
you are going to be this person when you
have none well it starts with activity
it starts with doing the stuff
and as an added correlator depending on
the goal that you have it might be what
would a person with a six-pack do what
would a pro-champion bodybuilder do what
would an amazing husband do or what
would the best husband in the world do
and so you can use this framework of
asking the question of what your ideal
self would do in any given circumstance
to apply to a vast number of scenarios
so rather than trying to fix for the
habit fixed for the being and then the
habits will take care of themselves in
accordance with the type of person that
you have stated you wish to become and
so then the goals we have become
becoming the person we want to be once
we know who we want to become then that
can direct the types of activities that
will be in accordance with that and the
reason i like this better too is that if
we're trying to reinforce an identity or
an identity trait about ourselves this
is a really good habit i think that i've
picked up over the years rule number
three stay driven recently i had uh some
of our some of our older og gym lords
who've been a while you know i mean they
they they turn their gym around they've
grown they're you know you know close to
seven figures or right around there and
they've been doing it for a while
and they were complaining about show
rates they're like hey our show rates
are low
and um you know you go through the same
well you're doing the reminders are you
doing all this stuff like yeah we're
doing all that stuff okay cool
and i dig a little bit deeper and i look
and it turns out that they're only open
one hour
per day
at 7 15 a.m
for their availability availability for
for new clients
and i'm like
do you think that you're going to grow
your business if the only time that you
can take new customers is that 7 15 a.m
in what world does that make sense right
like imagine a grocery store that's only
open from 7 to 7 30 because that's when
it's convenient for the owner what
chance do you think that that that
grocery store has at succeeding
virtually none and so what happens is
people have success they implement
tactics they use gym watch and then they
make money right and then what happens
they get comfortable they get complacent
right and they lose their hunger like
after that point everything like it's
almost like i was supposed to say like
after you after you've like quote made
it in your mind and that's what's funny
is that making it in some people's mind
is like having 10 grand at the bank
account so like it's scary in terms of
what level of making it is but like once
people have made it i almost want to say
like none of these tactics matter
because you're just not hungry like it
doesn't matter like the obvious [ __ ] you
aren't doing you know what i mean if
your child
was going to die or your spouse or your
city together your family member
whatever it was was going to die unless
you
succeeded unless you got more clients
unless you made more money with your gym
how would you approach it right would
you only be available for one hour a day
would you only be available from seven
to eight a.m would you only set aside an
hour a day to prospect for new customers
would you only reach out to your
customers if they hadn't shown up for a
month sometimes people ask questions
that they already know the answer to
it's like duh no [ __ ]
right and and and it goes back to the
the main thing which is like what drives
you right like what drives you what
drives you to be better what drives you
to continue to want to win i was asked
that question yesterday by the the gym
lords that were here and i think
honestly it comes from a dark place and
i think i've said this before but like
i'm saying it again because i think
people need to hear it sometimes you
have to wonder like why is it that only
when someone else's life is on the line
do you then actually try right like why
is it only then you actually cut all the
noise out of your life and then would go
laser focused on actually succeeding
like why can't
we
do that all the time right like why
can't we do that
because it's like well then i wouldn't
be happy whatever right like whatever
happiness means right and so the people
who are the most successful in the world
are driven by something that is deep
inside of them that is normally an
insecurity or a fear of some sort
if you are only trying to make enough to
live on you will always only make enough
to live on
and you will slack the moment you get
comfortable and you will wonder why is
it that as soon as i start making money
i stop because you actually don't want
to make more
that's why you actually don't want to
make more and so
your internal motivation is not there
like because you've accomplished what
you set out to accomplish the real
question is do you actually want what
you claim to want do you actually want
it because if you did you'd already have
it you'd already you'd already be
willing to sacrifice other things in
order to achieve it and that might mean
like maybe waking up earlier maybe like
working 4 to 8 p.m to take sales
appointments or whatever that thing is
it's just the obvious
like if you were coaching you
what would you recommend you to do right
like a lot of times if you think about
like
you most of the time know
what
to do like you do on some level like you
probably know that you're like man i do
stupid sometimes right you probably
think that on some level sometimes right
then you're like man if i were if you
could step out of yourself and say i
need to coach myself you probably have
the answer and it's just that you don't
do it for some reason and so all of your
attention should be on that reason why
is it that this thing has prevented me
from doing the things that i already
know i should do rule number four master
labeling our minds are meaning making
machines and so what that means is we
determine what is meaningful and what is
not and then we ascribe labels to them
in terms of positive and negative
because that is how we survive now that
being said our brains are meant to keep
us alive not meant to help us thrive
right to use a rhyming word for you now
that being said with this whole concept
around labeling it's something that i'm
probably most passionate about like the
concept of labeling as a whole it's
unbelievably powerful when it comes to
persuading people to do things
unbelievably powerful when it comes to
changing people's world views and their
perspectives on life and i will share a
few of those examples with you so i'll
give you a quick persuasion example for
how powerful this is if i wanted to
persuade someone to do something then
what i would do is i would create a
positive label that i would associate
them with so i would say you are
probably a loving and caring man for you
know you want to provide support for
your family is that true they're like
yes and i'm like yeah you definitely
seem like one of those types of people
and since you are one of those types of
people i think that you should invest in
this program that we have because that
would be an alignment with this ideal
that we just labeled the person with and
so what happens is it creates cognitive
dissonance because for the person in
order for them to stay in accordance
with the label that they would like to
have they then feel obligated to then
act in accordance with that label that
we just prescribed now that's a very
simplistic example you can weave that
into narratives and sales scripts so
that people become psychologically
labeled and then want to act in
accordance with that label because they
see it as positive right the thing is is
that it can also work in reverse in
terms of how you can harm someone and
the reason that this is so viscerally
upsetting to me is that i have had
members of my family extended and
whatnot who have i would say debilitated
themselves in large part because of what
they believe to be mental illness and i
disagree now many people will get
triggered at this and so i will say my
big disclaimer which is this is not
financial advice this is not grammatical
advice this is not spiritual advice this
is not even advice this is a guy making
youtube video about stuff that pisses me
off and hopefully some of the things
that serve me well now let's talk about
the labels that are negative one of the
things one of the most pernicious acts
that exists negative bad stuff is when
we take the human experience that has
ups and downs that has extremes that
exist on continuums and we label one
side of the continuum is bad and the
other side of the continuum is good for
example happy
sad
energized or weak tired right we have
equal opposites you know relaxed
stressed right there's lots of examples
of these the reason that this is so
dangerous when we give a positive or
negative label is that people think that
they have a problem when they are not
feeling happy or energized or
relaxed or clear-minded versus foggy you
know what i mean whatever and the thing
is is in order for there to be light
there must be darkness think about that
for a second
in order for there to be good there must
also be bad
one if you want to admit the existence
of one there must also be the existence
of the other
right awesome now the problem this is
why we have to be careful with labels
that most people suffer from is that
they label normal variations in the
human condition with negative
experiences and so they see themselves
as tired and say this is bad whereas
it's really just part of the human
condition they see themselves as sad
rather than happy and see that as bad
and so what happens is you start to
upgrade a finite emotional condition
into a long-standing emotional
disturbance because you think it's a
problem and the thing is it's very easy
to sell people on why these things are
our problems big pharma is is the king
of this are you feeling tired
stressed you know are you hungry are you
horny
well you are suffering from being a
human being it's being human and so i
think a lot of this and the reason that
it wraps into the original part of the
prompt of this video is that if we want
to be enduring entrepreneurs we want to
be people who have resilience we want
people who have mental fortitude we must
be careful about the things that we
label and there's also the good bad
label which is the simplest label that a
lot of people ascribe to conditions that
are that are
ephemeral right they're they're brief
right and then they change but there's
also the shoulds have
must
need to etc that we say in our lives
that we have to do these things we must
do these things and if we do not or else
we put out a threat towards the universe
if i don't get my coffee i must get my
coffee i need to have coffee before i
start my day what happens is that we
create these implied threats to
ourselves and the universe if we don't
then what
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there
rule number five act first one of the
things that i've seen across the board
when we're talking to entrepreneurs and
you know the the gym owner community
that we have is that
the one trait i see over and over again
that is clear to the people who are are
winners right the top one percent i'm
not talking top 10 percent but the top
one percent is the speed with which they
execute after making a decision one of
the definitions that like we talk about
in the community is that differential
power as i understand it is
the gap between thoughts becoming
reality and so if you thought about an
omnipotent being right something someone
who has unlimited power as they think
that thing would be right and so if you
were to believe in a creator of some
sort then you might think as that
creator thought the universe became
right and so if you think that is like
the ultimate scale of power
then the closer we can get to that the
more powerful we become the more potent
we are as entrepreneurs and so
i see this so many times that it's it's
not even it's not even oh like this is
associated with success like this is
what creates success because
the gap between where you decide
something is a good idea and when it
actually occurs is the loop with which
you can improve your business and so
it's a lot like
i can't remember what the saying was but
it's not like how old the car is but how
many miles are on it and what i mean by
that is like we're young right but
there's been a lot of a lot of
iterations that have happened from you
know when the business first started
when i started my first gym until now
and i think the key to that is the speed
of the ooda loop and that's that's just
like a military term like observe orient
decide to act and it's just the loop
with which that you can basically see
what's going on make a decision act on
it and then do that whole loop again
right because the faster you can pivot
and iterate the more responsive you are
as an entrepreneur the faster you can
take advantage of opportunities the
faster you can find out what failures
are and then move on i want to talk
about this within the context of running
a team and employees and then also
within yourself and so
from running your team right one of the
things that you know
once once you're moving out of you doing
things all the time there's how do i get
other people to do things and so that's
why i called this like week right is
that
i one of the things one of my biggest
pet peeves is like yeah i can get to
that by by end of week i'm like why
don't you just get it to me in an hour
because that's how long it takes and
then all of a sudden it's like oh it's
like well i have a meeting right then
it's like is it more important than this
no okay well then do it like if you
think about how you can run an
organization like that if you can get
things done end of day right rather than
end of week you are literally speeding
up the organization 7x think about that
and so when you're thinking about
deadlines and you're thinking about
expectations you as the owner can set
the x you set the cadence if people say
hey can we do this and then you're like
cool let's start right now
you set the tone for how the
organization's going to move how quickly
it's going to orient how quickly
thoughts become reality and ultimately
how powerful your organization will
become because of the speed right and
speed isn't doing things fast it's
basically just not being distracted by
others it doesn't matter it's being able
to prioritize and most people a lot of
the times aren't doing something that's
high priority right a lot of times
they're just doing nothing if you can
speed up that loop and
force and and put apply pressure to your
team to not do things by end of week or
even end of day it's like it's 10 am can
you get this done by noon uh okay and
then you can have that loop happen three
times within a day rather than it taking
three weeks right because you set that
cadence from the beginning and then
things get done faster so i've been
reading some really interesting books
lately you know and i refer them out to
um
a handful of entrepreneur friends that i
have that are all doing
five five to 15 million kind of in that
range and what was amazing to me is that
every single one of them
read the book immediately
sent me back their notes and what they
were going to do with it and at like and
basically were asking feedback on on the
angle that they were going to take with
it what's fascinating to me is that if
you look at if you look at lower level
entrepreneurs they and i'm not saying in
a negative way i'm just saying in terms
of just objective revenue like just they
haven't achieved this much the delay
between being able to gain information
and act is so much longer and that's why
they how where they want to be it's kind
of the same degree of people who are
like who pay for our program and haven't
gone through the poor yet i'm like what
do you do right like what priority like
what what education do you have that is
not relevant to your business like
you're reading a motivational blog right
now when
you have to translate that motivation
into a thought that you're then going to
quote test and then you have to see how
that test works and then maybe it
improves something rather than just
following the playbook that has already
been tested and has already like the the
tree has been shook right
and so
if you look at like joey for example who
by by all definitions his gym is the is
the number one gym within gym launch
right he had already finished everything
in legacy by week eight his first eight
weeks he'd already implemented every
single system in legacy and so it's not
like it's not like he has more hours in
the day right it's not like his business
is different it's just that his level of
efficacy in execution was so high
because it'd allow himself to get
distracted by things and the moment he
has something he needs to execute it's
creates this itch inside of him that he
cannot he can't move forward without
executing this so that the relief comes
and if you can start to foster that type
of behavior in yourself in those
attitudes about execution you will grow
faster and you will become more powerful
as an entrepreneur right if you think
about your competition who would you
fear right the competitor who sees what
you're doing
can immediately execute implement and
improve on it at a faster loop than you
can even understand what's going on
right and that's where speed of first to
market and things like that don't matter
as much because if an ex if a competitor
can execute an out ooda loop right can
can speed that loop up faster they can
iterate and improve on it faster than
you can and then you have no chance to
catch up and so if you're looking at
your business look at it from a context
of speed of how long does it take us to
improve things how long from
understanding that our churn is high to
executing the five horsemen how long did
that take we knew what the problem was
how long did it take for us to do and if
you can if you can if you can get real
with yourself about how many actual
hours it will take to do something and
then you look at your week and you think
okay what am i doing today that is more
important than this and where can i put
these two hours and start with the
moment that you make the decision and
then all of a sudden you'll be getting
things done that day that afternoon
rather than end of week end of month we
purposely delay these things because we
just procrastinate for no reason when
the the problem will not go away right
and so that is why within gym launch
speed is king is one of the core tenants
of the business because you have to and
the tone has to start with you as the
entrepreneur like you have to apply that
pressure you have to say end of week why
like what are you doing today that's
more important than this right what are
you doing in the next two hours that's
more important than this tell me right
and a lot of times you'll get the answer
like well i guess i can do it now it's
like yeah then let's do it now let's get
it done right and that small change
can 7x right if you even going from end
of week to end of day can 7x how quickly
your business grows because the
solutions that you need to implement to
solve the problems and break through the
bottlenecks happen today not in a week
not in a month and then the reaction to
the next thing that breaks the next
bottleneck in the business happens not
in a week not in a month but in a day
and then that's how quickly you can
pivot from where you are to where you
want to go because it's not one big
thing it's a million small turns that
will get you there rule number six find
a mentor you need someone who you can
trust like if you're giving someone your
money like or you're trying to take
someone's advice or counsel you need to
trust their intentions all right and so
it's not just whether they have
integrity it's whether they have your
best interest in mind all right so i'm
going to get to how i solve for that in
a second but that is the first character
trait of you need that you need of a
council of somebody of any kind of
counsel really whether it's investment
law et cetera
the second
is efficacy or their skill set right so
let's think of both let's think of just
different scenarios here so let's say
you might trust your mom implicitly but
she doesn't have the skill of knowing
much about you know how to structure
insurance policies or trusts or you know
investments in tech startups right you
might not have that skill but you might
trust her intention right for you
specifically on the reverse of that you
might see that there's this person who's
got lots of skill is prodigious in this
but it also means that they know exactly
how to screw you if they want to right
which is one of the double-sided things
of being really good at something right
you know all the details you know how to
write the agreement structure the deals
in order to make sure that you you know
get the best outcome right and so the
idea is to find someone who has both
your best interests at heart and has the
ability to deliver on what you want
right and so it's both of these things
since you're like well yeah
maybe that seems obvious for me just
even boiling it down to that was very
helpful for me because when i look and i
look through advisors look for people i
want to get counsel from i have to look
at these two things all right so here's
how i test for the integrity piece and
here's how you can kind of like you can
control for risk here right one is i
always try and interview as many
advisors as humanly possible all right
and i do that because i'm gonna get as
much information from each of the
council during this process that will
give me perspective from which to make a
judgment right one of the biggest
problems with this like if you think
about julie who's trying to lose weight
right she goes to the gym and then she
talks to 10 personal trainers one
personal trainer says it's all about
high fat low carb another guy says hey
don't worry about that keto stuff it's
all about high carb low fat and then
another guy says no you really just need
a balanced thing and another guy says
it's only about calories it's only about
counting your macros and so you get this
huge perspective so that hopefully you
can make a judgment call otherwise when
you talk to the first guy and he says
it's all about keto then you're like
well i guess this is it right i guess
these guys all have opinions when in
reality there is a truth you just don't
have the perspective in which to make a
judgement yet and so the first step in
this is that i interview as many as as i
possibly can from reputable sources so
this is where i reach out to my network
i make post etc to try and get as many
referrals as i can all right so that's
step one step two for the integrity
piece is that i try and have align
incentives now a lot of times they're
incentive systems that appear aligned
but not are not in reality so let me
give you an example so in the real
estate market if you're a realtor for
example you may think oh this realtor
has my best interest at heart right
because they have an incentive to sell
the house and so that is why they're
going to get compensated so they want to
sell it for as much as possible ah
but they aren't incentivized to sell it
for as much as possible they're
incentivized to sell as fast as possible
and get a deal closed all right and so
think about this
for you selling a house for 500 000
that's worth 500 000
is a normal you know that like that's
normal that's the market price right but
for you to make an extra let's say 25
000 or 50 000 would be really material
that would be a huge extra outcome for
you you would probably push a lot harder
to get the extra 25 or 50 000
now let's say that um you could probably
sell it in a day at 450 000 because it's
below the market value of the house
right now here's what's crazy is that if
a a selling realtor you know like total
might be seven percent two percent goes
to the buyer and five percent goes to
the seller if five percent is going to
your realtor five percent of five
hundred thousand dollars right is 25
grand okay and so for them
the the 50 000 decrease to drop you from
500 to 450 means that they're going to
give up 2500 so they're going to make 22
500. so let me ask you a question now
the reverse if they sell for 525 they're
going to get 27 500 right and so it's a
5 000 swing off of a you know 25 000 nut
for them and one of them might take them
three months and one of them might take
them a day so what is their incentive
their incentive is to get is to is to
make as much money as possible per unit
of time and so they're incentivized to
sell as fast as possible and so this is
one of those things where you have to
put your thinking cap on and say are our
incentives truly aligned and so when
we're looking at this when i say there's
two aspects that i look for counselor or
somebody who's going to help me do
something financially legally insurance
wise whatever it is so first is that
integrity piece and are there incentives
aligned the incentives being aligned and
you could restructure that deal and say
hey you know what you're gonna get zero
percent on anything below four hundred
thousand dollars i'll give you three
percent on anything between 400 and 450
and then from 450 and up i'll give you
20
right or 15 or whatever right and so now
they're highly incentivized to push and
now your incentives are aligned because
each increment for you is worth almost
as much it is to them and that is how
you would align incentives all right now
how do you test for the second thing
which is their skill set
this one's hard all right especially if
you don't have the perspective from
which to make a judgment which when i
enter new things when i'm trying to
learn about trust and i'm trying to
learn about investment things and
different vehicles i'm learning about
storage units more about multi like
you're like man there's so much stuff
and there's so much nuance that you have
to have right and so the first thing is
i like to usually read two to three
books on the topic all right and i read
two to three books just so i don't
appear like an idiot um and so i can at
least understand what they're saying and
they're gonna respect you to they will
it's kind of like defense if you bring
your if you bring at least some level of
knowledge they don't feel like they're
gonna take advantage of you so this is
this is the first thing i do and this is
because i don't like feeling exposed in
these types of conversations the second
thing you can do is if you have someone
that you can trust you can bring them in
alongside you and the third thing that
you can do which is probably the the
most and highest recommended is
repeating the same action i said in the
first hand which is try talk as to as
many of them as possible and then you
will gather the insights and you'll see
the people who demonstrate the most
expertise and what you can do is take
what one person says and say well what
about this and see what they reply with
right and as you gain more and more
knowledge and this is how you so in the
consulting world this is qualitative
research right this is where you're
literally doing interviews essentially
to gather information so that you can
make an informed decision right and so
when you do these interviews and this is
what this is the lazy part this is what
most people don't do they won't do this
work right they won't take the time to
interview 20 people or 10 people when in
reality these one decisions the guy who
you decide to you know invest in in
their fund or if you decide to buy this
building or invest in a fund that buys x
y and z right or you or you have
somebody who manages your portfolio
whatever it is right that one decision
can be one of the most if not the
biggest influence on your total net
worth over a long period of time and
people take more time to figure out what
they want to where they want to go on
vacation than where they're going to put
their money right and so my ask to you
is that if you if you put these put
these lenses on think about both of
these lenses lens one do i think this
person is integris do i think this
person has my best interest at heart and
then two do they have the skill to
deliver on that promise because i don't
want my mom doing my investments i know
she has my best at heart but she has no
idea what she's doing and then i don't
want somebody who absolutely knows what
they're doing and does not have my best
interests at heart right which honestly
unfortunately is a lot more of the cases
that you'll come up with and candidly
you know a lot of times they're
literally incentivized against you you
know uh in in the insurance industry
they're kind of incentivized to rip you
off it's it's it's pretty terrible and
there's a lot of industries like that
mortgage brokers are incentivized to rip
you off and so you really have to look
at it from both lenses and these types
of decisions can make the biggest impact
on your net worth in your financial
future simply based on who you decide to
work with rule number seven recognize
talents when i started in this business
i took every single sale and it was
because i was so afraid that somebody
would waste the opportunity so if you
have that fear i understand where you're
coming from second when i had my first
sale that was not me i i just had this
emotional breakdown because i was like
oh my god this could actually happen and
i promise you if you haven't had it
happen yet you will when it does because
you realize that this business can
actually work without you and other
people can make it rain too right and
then i'll tell you a quick story that
illustrate the next point that i'm gonna
make so as i you know hired some sales
people now that first sales person were
they exceptional no but they were able
to get the job done later on i had my
first kind of like killer um and his
name was mauro negretti and he uh he
came
in i don't know a year or two into the
business a year into the business and
he
so quickly was able to assume the sales
role and to show you how laughable this
is
he started and
i was about to start training him and
some lady walked in the door
and i was like hey man like i can take
he's like no i'm good he's like go do
your thing he's like fitness nutrition
accountability okay i'll figure it out
and he ended up closing this first lady
who walked in the door for paid in full
and i remember walking in like
completely dumbstruck i was like he
didn't even know what the pitch was but
she walked out giggling happy so excited
to start and
what that
moment taught me was that
it is good to train sales people but
it's better to take great sales people
and then just
point them in a direction and so this
has informed a lot of the thinking that
i have around talent in general and i'll
tell you a couple of frameworks that
have informed this but like if you look
at harvard harvard doesn't produce the
smartest people
they select the smartest people and then
they put
smart uh professors in front of them but
like the base level of intelligence of
everyone who's at harvard is already
exceptionally high and so like even if
the teachers at harvard were not
exceptional the students are and they
would be successful independent of that
because their selection is so ridiculous
right and so if we can think about our
own companies that way and especially if
you're in the service business like look
at the biggest service companies out
there like look at mckinsey look at bain
look at bcg look at basically a lot of
the finance world is or service based
businesses a lot of times right and
they're able to do that because they
create such a pool to select from that
they are able to skim for the best
talent right i heard this uh quote from
uh estrella kathy who's the founder of
chick-fil-a you win the championship in
the draft and so it was such a belief
that they had about picking the right
people even more so than training and i
would say that i have moved in that
direction of a little bit more nature
than nurture when it comes to
roles specifically sales especially
there are certain characteristics about
building rapport about having certain
you know dynamics or energy whatever you
want to say that like mar negrete when
he walked in he had all of these things
and he didn't even know the pitch but he
won that sale off of just pure rapport
and so if i'm going to allocate the same
level of time to training somebody i
might as well start with somebody who
has a much higher base because i could
spend 10 hours to take someone from a
two to a four and a half or i could
spend the same 10 hours taking someone
from a six to a nine and the thing is
i'm also gonna get more bang for my buck
in terms of my hours of training with
somebody who has not a natural
proclivity for selling compared to
somebody who does not what's interesting
about this and this is just like my
observation is that you just have to be
willing to talk to more people in the uh
recruiting process i will say like from
a recruiting standpoint there's there's
two kind of things to look out for if
you're if you're if you cannot pay
super handsomely based on your price
points which you need to maybe fix later
but like if you can't pay super well for
the sales person then you need to look
harder and you'll need to interview more
people and you'll need to probably run
ads and use your network if you can pay
well the best sales people are already
employed and so it comes down to
recruiting those sales people from other
sales jobs ideally from companies just
like yours so that they already know a
lot of the things coming into it so it
decreases the ramp up time for them
because all we're really doing is
swapping products and the actual sales
cycle the type of sale is it a
transactional sales a long sale is it a
software sale is it a coaching program
cell whatever it is right there's so few
variables that were changing that they
can immediately jump and go which also
allows you to make a judgment on their
proficiency faster and so as a quick
side note to this because this is
something that i've given a lot of
thought if you look at the top sales
people and sales trainers and this is
going to drive point drive home the
point that i was making earlier about it
being
much of it being born all right is that
if you look at the top people who are in
the space you look at jordan belford
right you look at bradley you look at
and some people would would say me in
term from a selling perspective all the
guys that i know who have taught sales
were exceptional salespeople day one
bradley started selling cars when he was
18 years old was the top salesman at 18
years old when he started and he was
like i just found something i was really
good at jordan belford talks about how
he didn't know how to train anybody in
his book and then all of a sudden he for
the first time ever wrote out a
framework to explain the straight line
sales system which became his book and
all that kind of stuff but he up to that
point it was just what he naturally
did right and i can tell you in my
instance as well i'd already closed
thousands of deals before i even
consumed my first sales training and so
like i do think that if we are selecting
salespeople i think it's much more about
selection than is about training the
training is to remind them how good they
are not necessarily to make them good
all right and this is something that has
shifted over time for me specifically
now if you're like well i suck at sales
you can absolutely put way more time
into yourself than a business would
recently put into an employee all right
like you have you all the time so you
can train you in all your off hours and
you're spending your own time to invest
in yourself but from a return on
investment perspective
it's the cost of finding a good
salesperson compared to the cost of
training a bad or mediocre salesperson
is significantly lower it's much easier
to find the right people than it is to
take somebody and then make such a crazy
extensive training unless your entire
model is we just take on every single
person who walks in the door like 24
hour fitness has this model they take on
anybody who has a pulse and then they
put them through a ridiculous culling
process and then 10 of people make it in
the first 90 days rule number eight
manage your attention a lot of people i
would say mistakenly think that the
number one resource is time
right everyone's like time is money time
is money time is money
and i would argue that that's not
necessarily true i would argue that
attention is money that is the golden
resource so the billionaire friend that
i have he's actually been helping me on
um the new endeavor that we are
launching to our gym lords uh soon which
i think will change the industry anyways
he's been helping me with that stuff but
like here's an example
on his phone his phone does not ring
unless you are already a contact that
has been whitelisted
his phone doesn't ring it's he's
impossible to reach the more successful
the more the the larger your company
grows the more you scale the more you
need to scale the only way to scale you
is because you do have a finite amount
of attention and so what happens is you
have to decrease all of the other things
in your life that drain attention
because you can have as much time as you
want but if you're not there you're not
potent you're not able then you can't
get anything done with that time that
you're supposedly allocating which is
why a lot of people end up in this in
between state of
always everywhere and at the same time
nowhere right and so they're they're
everywhere but they're not paying
attention to anything and that's and the
reason that it's difficult to focus is
because entrepreneurs the character
trait that made us into entrepreneurs is
that we're go getters we're we're
risk-averse we're creators we're
innovators we're builders right we have
all of those traits but the difficulty
is is that the thing that gets you from
zero to one is not the thing that gets
you from one to two right and so one of
the the reason that you have to totally
morph and why you have to be a growth
oriented individual is because you have
to change your own
individual character traits in order to
progress as a business owner and so like
i said the things that got you here are
not the things that are going to get you
there the things that got you here which
is your own internal skills are not the
things that you need to pass on to other
people so the only way that you were
able to grow your business at a certain
point is by growing other people right
and the only way you can do that is if
you have the attention and the bandwidth
in order to do so and that's why if you
look at a business owner and like the
more i obsess on looking at billionaires
and people who are we're doing better
than we are is i look at how quiet and
how clean they keep their space and i
mean that both in a literal sense that
like their surroundings their office
their house their homes their cell phone
their computers right there it's it's
it's quiet right everything like it's
it's pristine
and when you talk to these people
there's a certain amount of of
tranquility that's there and
and they just they just have very low
tolerance
and it's not that they're trying to be
impatient with you or impatient with the
world it's just that they understand
that they have so like they're they're
operating at such a high level that
there's so many things that are
demanding of their time and attention
that they just like they can't and so
they have to forcibly remove themselves
from so many different situations and
i'm going to give you an example so one
of the people that i'm i'm i'm somewhat
mentoring right they had they had four
businesses and this is something that
that happens so many times it lit like
like you want you want a hundred
thousand dollar coaching this is what
happens in hundred thousand dollar
coaching sessions and i'm being honest
with you what happens is someone who's
coming in usually doing between one and
three million dollars a year um can't
get past a certain point right and the
reason they can't get past is because
they only have so much attention they've
spread between four or five different
cases that's when the gym owner has four
gyms and is making less money than they
did when they had one gym because the
amount of attention that they can
allocate to one facility has gone down
so much that with fixed costs they
basically are breaking even right and so
the same thing happens now that
entrepreneur is probably making one to
three million dollar in gross revenue
but not taking anything home because
they don't have the attention actually
put onto things and so in order to grow
you need to do less
in order to grow you need to do less
and that comes from both delegation and
also
choosing what not to do the better you
get the better the opportunities that
you have to say no to
imagine the level of opportunities that
we have now i'm just being honest so
imagine
how many things we could do or trying jv
with or do a partnership with or
whatever because of the distribution
network that we have and the trust and
the goodwill that we have with the gym
owners um that we have in our network
right a lot i get i you know how many
people
cold message me like i have an
opportunity for you i'm like really you
have an opportunity for me and so the
better you get the better your
opportunities you have to say no to
which is why becoming a higher and
higher and higher level entrepreneur is
more and more difficult because it
requires discipline
it's not about doing more it's about
doing less because we innately want to
do more so doing more of your own
internal characteristic if that was what
it took to get to be more successful
then everyone would be more successful
because it would be something that does
not take effort because that is
something that we already do it's like
man i outwork anyone i've got all this
work with it cool that gets you from
zero to one
it's not gonna get you any further than
that so stop identifying with that it
was something that i used to identify
with i was like i'll outwork anyone
or whatever like that was something that
i used to think about and it was a
character trait it was an identity thing
and the more you grow the more you
realize that your identity needs to be
fluid because what it needs to be is
exactly what it needs to be at that
given time of development because the
character traits that i'm going to have
to emphasize in a year are going to be
different than the ones that i have to
emphasize now the skills that you need
to learn like delegation
leadership those are things that are not
the things that take you in the
beginning you have to be independent you
have to be a hustling you have to be
grinding you have to be willing to put
in the work because no one else will do
it for you especially if you have no
capital to start which most of the
people who are on here are in that
situation to reel this back in
the number one thing that you have to be
paying attention to
is where you are paying your attention
right like you spend attention that's
why they call it paying attention it's
because it is a resource and most people
don't pay attention to that right and so
one of the things that a lot of people
don't know about me this one's going to
go along um
some of the things that a lot of people
don't know about me is that i for
nine months
paid a coach
to teach me one thing which was to
manage my attention was to teach me how
to think
and so for 90 minutes every single day
all i did was talk about what i was
thinking about
think about that
every day i paid attention to where my
attention was
and when i did that all of a sudden my
business blew up
right and i realized that i had toxic
relationships i had toxic relationships
with parents i had toxic relationships
with friends or pseudo-friends things
that i that were taking my attention
past things that i had on my mind that i
knew i had not handled so those are
called like open loops or open cycles
right so when you have something that
you like i haven't resolved this then
you need to handle that and you'll get
that attention back because what happens
is you have this bowl this tiny little
bowl of marbles that each of those
marbles is is a unit of attention right
if you had to measure it and so you put
little marbles of attention on your
childhood traumas you put little marbles
of attention on your marriage you put
little uh marbles of attention on your
health you put little marbles of
attention on your spirituality and then
massive marbles of attention on your
business but the thing is is that
sometimes you need to quiet and collect
all of these other little marbles so
that you have more potency more
potential energy more potential units of
attention to spend on the one thing that
you're trying to grow which in this case
would be your business and what's
interesting is that what happens is that
things that were perceived as difficult
become really easy and i don't know if
you've ever had this happen but like if
you were in college or you were in high
school and you were like man i can't
solve this problem this math problem and
you were exhausted then you go to bed
and you wake up the next morning and
then all of a sudden it seems really
easy you're like i don't know why i
didn't see that before because attention
gives you the ability to see
right like if you're if you think about
wisdom right wisdom is an ability to see
what other people cannot see
right two people are presented the same
situation the wiser person sees things
that the other person doesn't and how
can you see better you see better if you
have more ability to see which comes
from your most valuable resource
attention how much horsepower do you
have and so look at the things that you
have in your in your life right now like
if i see someone who has a messy
relationship wife who's got a messy love
life who goes out every weekend and gets
trashed right like i can tell you
billionaires don't do that that like the
whole tony stark like
vision of the entrepreneur is a farce
it's not true don't believe that every
single billionaire every single
high-level entrepreneur is quiet
unbelievably quiet they keep themselves
completely isolated they have a bubble
around them of of layers of protection
they're like like for me it's it's
me and then there's layla and then we
have our co and then we have our
executive assistant team because we have
a team of eas at this point we have four
um who work the next level there's no
one who has direct access to me
including our employees no one does
and that's because it's it would
disserve you
you guys our gym owners if everyone had
access to me the reason that i don't
respond to facebook messages is not
because i don't want to it's because i
literally can't and if i did i would be
disturbing everyone because then my
attention would be split because someone
can't generate leads in their mind or
whatever you know what i mean like
because these little things these little
things that are perceived as huge issues
to you in that moment because you have a
little bit of attention
you you have so little left that
everything seems like an explosion but
when you have lots of capacity big
problems seem small and small problems
seem big and it sounds reverse because
what you do is you start seeing that all
of these things are attention drains and
you just say i don't want to play
anymore
then you stop playing rule number nine
discover what people want
most business strategies are not
complicated find something that's
something
find something people want charge a lot
of money for it and deliver that thing
really well so much so that they tell
other people about your product it's not
overwhelmingly complex to consider the
execution is difficult but the concept
is not and so a lot of people think
they're going to win on strategy when
they're starting a business when you
could have two people who have lawn care
companies and one person has a long care
company with a billion dollars one
person that can barely break five
thousand dollars a month it's not
because the strategy is significantly
different it's just the execution how is
it that an entrepreneur or two
entrepreneurs can start at the exact
same time and one can be get 10 20 30
times faster or when you start over
again you can always skip these steps to
get to your level of incompetence my
theory around this comes down to pattern
recognition and let me explain it's not
just pattern recognition from the
perspective that you have strategies or
something that you're you're recognizing
but actually patterns in people and so
i'm going to give this a quick story to
drive this this point home i have
struggled for the last decade to find uh
an assistant and so it's one of the
things i'm actually you know a little
embarrassed about but i i've gone over
seven on assistance um so much so to the
point that i was just i almost kind of
gave up just even trying to find an
assistant and until recently i every
time i had an assistant it just always
right off the bat it just never felt
like right and i always was like yeah
maybe it'll get better it'll get better
at it and they just never really did and
the problem was that i didn't know what
it looks like when it's right and so in
the videos that i talk about i use the
word the term ideal scene i don't know
what the ideal scene of this
dynamic looks like when we are scaling
companies right and i'll tell you what i
found out there in a second but like
when we're scaling companies what we
have to do is pay down ignorance tax of
knowing what ideal scene looks like
which is where speed comes from having
people who have outside eyes look in who
already do know what i steal ideal scene
looks like so you can skip steps faster
and so i'll give you an example what
this looks like in real life like for me
in the role of executive assistant thank
god that like for me it wasn't a
necessary thing to continue to grow the
businesses now that i have one i don't
ever really want to live life without
one but
the entire time i kept bringing people
in i didn't know what to look for we do
hiring you know we do the hiring process
we do an onboarding and training process
they never really got up to speed or we
never really got in sync and then i'd
slowly kind of fall away there would be
distance and then it became kind of
awkward and then i would end up having
to cut the relationship and so in this
instance we immediately synced up i
really like the person i trust the
person and they are so proactive in all
aspects of my life that i just sit down
and start working and then she places
things in front of me i'm like hey i got
13 minutes she's like cool do this i'm
like i've got you know 18 minutes here
she's like cool do this and do this and
every time i'm done i'm like hey what
else should i do she's like boom and so
we meet based on the priorities that i
have and then she has this big stack and
knows how long every every one of these
things takes because i talk to her about
how long i think the tax will take and
then as i have openings we slot it in so
it's like i wake up and i'm just
crushing work until the end of the day
because i know that the amount of time
that's been allotted for each of the
task is the appropriate amount of time
and so and if i do finish early i get
another task done right and so we can we
can we can crush stuff and rule number
10 the last one before some very special
bonus clips is don't let fear stop you
me quitting my job was the single
hardest decision that i've ever made in
my entire life and i mean that genuinely
it was the hardest decision that i've
made it took me six months to do it and
i listened to arnold's rules of success
speech every morning when i wake up
about you know it's okay to fail and i
had to keep saying this stuff because i
was so outwardly driven i was so status
driven that i didn't want to take the
risk of being seen as a failure and so
it only was when i was literally
confronted with my own
you know the fact that i was really not
even willing to be alive anymore is when
that was kind of my jogging to awaken
this moment where i was like you know
what if i don't even want to be alive
anymore then what's worse than that and
so that was what ultimately shot me on
the trajectory to you know quit that job
sell the condo put everything that i had
in my car and i drove across the country
in 36 hours to california which is where
i thought the land of fitness
opportunity would be now mind you i was
a management consultant we did space
cyber intelligence for the military
at a subcontractor of booz allen if
you're familiar with that consulting
firm and that's what i did for two years
and it sounds really you know cool and
sexy but it was not at all for me and i
really did not enjoy it but i learned
some valuable lessons like how to learn
while i was there and so i think that
what most people you know it really
depends on who you are and understanding
your skill set and honestly and how much
pain you're in and so there's also
different ways to satisfy that pain i
think true to my core if i
had been in a different company or i was
working on different projects at that
time in my life i probably would have
never quit it was so hard for me and i
didn't have a wife i didn't have kids i
had zero dependents and i lived on
nothing and it was still one of the
hardest decisions of my life because i'm
very risk-averse so believe it or not
most entrepreneurs you know a lot of
people talk about how they you know they
didn't do well in school and you know
teachers never understood them they
always knew they had to go out on their
own i never had any of that i worked
really hard in school i did really well
in school teachers liked me for the most
part and you know i got a good job
afterwards and so i did not have the
traditional entrepreneur journey
and it was only because i was so sad
deeply depressed in that time of my life
and felt so empty that i actually made
the jump and so i think the first thing
is like one are you are you incredibly
sad are you credibly dissatisfied with
your life so much so that you'd be
willing to uproot and change number one
number two entrepreneurship is not easy
and so if you need i think elon musk
said this on a clubhouse meeting and i
just think it's so true people were like
what words of motivation would you give
for a new entrepreneur if you need
motivational quotes or motivational
words then entrepreneurship isn't for
you and i tend to agree with it like if
you need that motivation like
it is one of the loneliest paths
period you know at least in co-workers
you have other people who are around you
you can but when you start on your own
you're starting at zero with no one and
basically no one's rooting for you like
for me when i left like no one really
supported me um my parents thought i was
stupid and that this was a stupid idea i
was throwing my education away and i was
risking everything just go start a gym
right which is really not even that good
of a return on investment you know what
i mean but i was so committed to the
fact that i was so miserable that i was
like at least i can just live my life
doing something that i enjoy i don't
even care if i make money and that was
literally the the mindset that i was
able to to quit with
and so
i'd again i don't know where you're at
but the first piece of this is
understanding short and long-term
payoffs i did not make
a significant amount of money for years
after i quit my job all right so i'd say
for the first
four years
i essentially broke even and made less
money than i did as a consultant all
right so like think about that for a
second right now there's a lot of
mistakes i made too and you're going to
make them as well because none of us is
perfect there's so many skills that you
have to like you have to acquire so many
skills to run a business right and so
you may have a single job right now and
you are you are doing one specific
function of one specific sub department
of a business but in order to be an
entrepreneur you have to understand all
of it right in order to be a successful
entrepreneur so you have to understand
how to generate demand you have to
generate understand how to generate
leads you have to understand how to work
leads you have to understand how to sell
you have to extend how to fulfill and
deliver and how to manage people how to
communicate how to relay expectations
how like how to recruit how to hire how
to interview like there's so many things
that you have to learn and i don't want
that to be overwhelming i just want to
confront you with reality because
honestly if i knew
how hard it was going to be when i
started my first business i don't know
if i would have done it
i just i forced myself into a hole and i
always like to say this is you'd be
surprised what you can accomplish when
you have no choice as as dark and morbid
as i'm gonna as what i'm gonna say is
and don't get triggered by this but like
the fact that an entire race in our
country was enslaved for hundreds of
years and was still able to do that
every day shows the strength of the
human spirit and what is possible when
you have no choice and so i think that
to juxtapose what i said about how hard
it is if you can put yourself in a
position where you have no choice you
will be successful right if you want to
succeed as bad as you can breathe you
will be successful and so i think that
was the situation where i was in where i
was
i knew that the alternative to what i
was doing was death for me and so it was
just anything is better than this and
honestly the next
you know year of my life even after that
was still incredibly hard but it was
different but it was still incredibly
hard
a keystone habit that has served me very
well and it's only been in retrospect
explaining it to someone else that i
kind of had more clarity on it which is
why i'm sharing it with you when i have
something that i want that i do not have
so i have a desire which means i've made
a contract with myself to be unhappy
until i get what i want right and so i
have this thing that i want externally
and i think i've had enough experience
with this to know that simply writing
down the goal means nothing and so i
think this is contrary to common belief
or practice which is like people write
down their goals are more likely to
succeed sure i mean having a direction
is more likely to achieve than than not
having a direction so i'm not going to
disagree with that but here's an
interesting statement that
may hit you which is that winners and
losers have the same goals right
everybody olympics has the same goal
everybody who's in business has the same
goal right they want to increase how
much money they're making you sell more
products get more customers etc so the
goals are actually not that unique and
so the fact that we're writing them down
sure it's a first step because we have
to have a direction in terms of what are
we trying to accomplish sure but i think
that what you'll see that is different
because if you look at two people with
the same goals and one person achieves
them the other person hasn't then it
can't be having the goal that is the
main driver of success right right and
so then you get you know you dive a step
underneath that and you look at what are
the behaviors that created that goal and
now we get much closer to the things
that are actually driving the progress
what gets more interesting at least to
me is if we know the activities that are
going to generate the result we want so
maybe it's we want to get more customers
which means we need to advertise more
and i use advertised by the definition
of what the word actually means which is
to make known and so if we do activities
that make our products and services
known like doing more private
communications which would be one-on-one
reach outs one-on-one cold calls 101 dms
101 emails et cetera prospecting or one
to many so public communication which
should be uh you know broadcasting
across different platforms for media
right so you have radio you could have
an email list you could have um actually
that would be an example of a high
version of scale of the original so i
apologize there but like making posts on
social media things that are public
forum where people can find out about it
right if you do more of those things
more people find out and that would be
the activity that's associated with
getting more customers right but the
thing is is that people will know what
that activity is right they will know
that inherently they should be doing
more of it and yet they don't
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome for 50
more amazing rules from garyvee check
the video right there next to me i think
you'll love it continue to believe i'll
see you there for me happiness is being
able to do what you want to do at all
times
so not conforming making nothing yeah
just being able to do what you want to
do
who wouldn't want that and i think